les trompettes du dialogue en bouche et
avec vigueur par les socialistes
allemands ceux de vibrantes et ceux de
valter houle briest feront elles tomber
ce mur de berlin ce mur qui divise
l'allemagne
si les pourparlers aboutissent vie libre
et fritz ehrler et herbert trainer
franchiront le mur au check point
charlie
ici dans une dizaine de jours peu après
des représentants du régime de l'est se
rendront à hanovre en république
fédérale
ces échanges de tribun sont le premier
pas sur le long chemin de la
réunification allemande
deux raisons ont amené vibrante à saisir
au vol la balle qu'on lui lancer par
dessus le mur et a proposé aux gens de
pankov des réunions publiques dans
chaque partie de l'allemagne
première raison le mur de berlin
continue de faire des victimes
et ce n'est pas en tournant le dos à
olbricht que les propos s'arrêteront de
tirer sur les fugitifs
deuxième raison en allemagne de l'ouest
on commence à penser qu'il faut agir
maintenant qu'il faut que les allemands
agissent eux mêmes pour la réunification
de l'allemagne et que l'attentisme ne
paie plus c'est ce qui a incité le
chancelier est rare qu approuver la
décision de la spd de se rendre en
allemagne de l'est
qu'allez vous leur dire je vais leur
parler de leur sort et de possibilités
de l'heure
faire arriver quelques soulagement dans
leur vie quotidien mais je suis
convaincu que dans la salle il y aura
surtout les fidèles du parti communiste
mais ça ne fait rien parce que nous
assistons à une transmission libre par
la télévision par la radio afin que
chaque allemand puisse être témoin de
cette discussion
et que croyez vous que les gens de la sd
vous répondront ils répondront
probablement en eau disant oh vous
pouvez avoir beaucoup plus de
soulagement si vous acceptez que l'on
nous regardent comme et en deuxième et à
l'indépendant il souverain en terre
allemande qu'au fond nous nous regardons
les uns les autres comme des citoyens de
pays étrangers
c'est une position que nous ne pouvons
ni comprendre ni accepter parce que
c'est notre petite patrie commune
on a parlé de la possibilité d'une
confédération allemande
qu'en pensez vous on ne peut pas
confédérés dans une seule confédération
un pays où il y a de la liberté une
partie des tâches et de ce pays il n'ya
pas de liberté de l'autre côté du mur il
ne fait aucun doute que la décision de
vie libre et de ses amis a suscité une
petite panique au sein de l'appareil du
parti personne ne s'attendait ici
heureusement que les propositions de
dialogue fut acceptée val terroriste a
d'ailleurs mis un certain temps à
reprendre contenance et à engager les
pourparlers sur un terrain plus pratique
au sein même du parti on discute
actuellement sans repos pour savoir quel
orateurs opposé à vie vivante et fritz
ehrler que leur répondre le débat devra
t'il être retransmis par la télévision
devra-t-on laisser entrer tout le monde
dans la salle des débats et cetera
autant de questions qui sont encore sans
réponse une chose est sûre en tout cas
c'est que la décision d'engagement du
dialogue a été accueillie très
favorablement
avec joie peut-on dire par l'homme de la
rue par la population si bien sûr ici
les commentaires publics sont encore
très réservé il est à noter que nos yeux
des fans de l'organe du parti publiant
la lettre de philippe brandt
aoun briest s'est vendu une heure après
sa parution à un prix égal à 100 fois
son prix normal au marché noir
tous les regards se tournent maintenant
vers le mur la question se pose qu'en
sera-t-il sa dernière victime
le dialogue fait reprendre espoir à
l'allemagne sans que toutefois personne
ne se fasse d'illusions
la route sera très longue